we serve an industry that for a very
long time has been fragmented they each
have unique services delivered in unique
ways with unique back-office operations
unique pricing and so forth fulcrum
offer is a solution set that helps run
the entire back-office it's built on si
P that allows you to scale globally and
allows you to scale horizontally with
respect to the breadth of services the
legal industry and specifically law
firms they care dearly about
confidentiality data privacy conflicts
things like that are very important to
them they're regulated and managed on
that at a level that no other can
compare iBM has provided as an
infrastructure with almost 60 data
centers around the world to accommodate
the growth of these firms as well as the
requirements of these firms si P is
highly standardized very proven and has
state-of-the-art technology behind it
iBM has got all that under control they
have the best engineers they have the
most broad network and then when you an
consider some of their advancements like
the Watson licenses and other things it
really gives us a very formidable
offering so this offering the formative
ility of that offering the combination
of the number one business software
provider in the world and si P the
number one infrastructure of IBM and the
number one legal offering a solution set
by fulcrum it's unparalleled and that's
why we decided to make that step forward
IBM became the first certified partner
to have s a ps4 Hana on bare metal
servers this is what I mean when I say
lead the way bare metal servers are
already not only in existence but
setting this new standard for how we
want to run our infrastructure start
back at what fulcrum has already ramped
up on the s4 on that platform and in
institutionalized all of our
requirements into that and now we have
the opportunity to take our clients
today into a global back-end in first
that is already on their metal surface
using us for some of the metrics that we
can take advantage of the KPIs is really
focused around how the firm is able to
get the most bang for its buck in other
words leverage the amount of expenditure
that it has in operational expenditures
or reduce capex and keeping a small
balance sheet while still producing the
most profits per partner for the firm
revenues per partner for the firm and so
on with IBM Watson we can now take
machine learning and AI and we can have
the systems learn the back-office
scenarios as that data flows through so
effectively as the firm grows I don't
have to keep adding people to my back
office rather I can let the system get
smarter and they can deliver the
difference
[Music]
you